en 14 années chez cae
c'est bien la première fois que le
patrice massicotte assemble non pas des
simulateurs de vol mais des respirateurs
bien plus engageant comme projet que ça
pour nous l'équipe c'est ce qui les
motive et à tout les jours de la fierté
de baptiste produits lot
il s'agit du cae r1 un respirateur
entièrement fabriqués au canada 500
employés de l'entreprise et 130
fournisseurs externes travail pour
honorer le contrat obtenu avec le
gouvernement canadien au mois d'avril
santé canada a aussi certifié des
respirateurs produit par deux groupes
canadiens
cae et le consortium 24 heures ils vont
maintenant pouvoir augmenter leur
production pour fabriquer et 20000
respirateur commandé dix mille unités
doivent être livrés d'ici l'automne 750
27 ans à même de dire 500 pièces cud 1
500 pièces à assembler et ça veut aussi
dire un ventilateur au 7 mai on est
capable de développer et de rapidement
évidemment de fabriquer assembler des
unités advenant une aux crises futures
l'innovation de ce produit réside
également dans son interface
d'utilisation avec un seul doigt je
capable d'aller chercher une information
rapide
d'autres entreprises ont transformé
leurs lignes de production pour fournir
du matériel médical sheba were on a
troqué les patins à glace et les
équipements de hockey contre des
visières de protection on a commencé au
début avec un volume de 10 mille visière
père semaine donc au début on était une
vingtaine de personnes et on a augmenté
jusqu'à 200 milles visions personnelles
depuis le début de la pandémie deux
millions de visiteur médical ont été
fabriquées aujourd'hui l'entreprise
renault avec le sport avec des visières
anti-buée pour les entraîneurs et les
spectateurs mais aussi un dispositif
anti gouttelettes intégrer un nouveau
masque de hockey
ce nouveau produit qu on off cet été
pour permettre aux jeunes de retourner
au jeu en toute sécurité
ici à smic ryan radio canada montréal